WAI CHEE DIMOCK: Last
time, we talked about the
odd presence of race in
The Great Gatsby.
Even though there's no
African-American character in
iThe Great Gatsby/i, there's an
undercurrent of allusions
to race, especially in that
seemingly gratuitous scene
when Nick and Gatsby are going
to town in Gatsby's car, and
they see this other car with
two black men and one black
woman in a car driven by
a white chauffeur.
So that's a very odd, gratuitous
reference.
And I just want to pick
up on that and push
that a little further.
Because there actually is a more
important connection of
African-American music,
actually, being very important.
And I would say that jazz
started out as and is still
very much African-American
music.
So Fitzgerald has written an
essay-- this is after The
Great Gatsby--
but 1931 essay called, "Echoes
of the Jazz Age." And he says,
"It was an age of miracles, it
was an age of art, it was an
age of excess, and it was
an age of satire."
So a lot of those terms,
"miracles"--
you guys will probably
know this--
there's a very strong religious
language, language
of Christianity--
"son of God"--
religious language in
The Great Gatsby.
And miracles would be within
that domain of religious
allusions, but obviously
being remapped
onto a secular context.
But certainly Gatsby is someone
who would believe in
miracles, the miracle of
turning time back and
completely erasing a few
years of Daisy's life.
That's the miracle that
he wants to achieve.
So miracles, what Fitzgerald
associates with the Jazz Age,
very much is a very important
term for The Great Gatsby.
Excess, we know about, and
age of art as well.
And there's actually
an allusion.
When Nick goes to Gatsby's
party, the music that was
playing is actually the "Jazz
History of the World." So lots
of cross-references, basically a
kind of a web, a musical web
that's being woven into The
Great Gatsby, with jazz being
the genetic ground
of that web.
And jazz really was important
to the 1920s, not just to
Fitzgerald but to the entire
decade, so I just want to
bring up some other
important figures.
The piece called "(What Did I Do
to Be So) Black and Blue,"
that's an especially
resonant piece.
It started out with Fats Waller
singing it in "Ain't
Misbehaving." And then it was
picked up, both played on the
trumpet but also sung
by Louis Armstrong.
And then there's an allusion
to Louis Armstrong in Ralph
Ellison's Invisible Man.
And for some reason, that is not
showing up here, so I must
have erased that when I was
getting ready for this.
So I'll just read this to you.
This is the opening of Ralph
Ellison's Invisible Man.
"Then somehow I came out of
it, ascending hastily from
this underground of sound
to hear Louis Armstrong
innocently asking, 'What did I
do to be so black and blue?'"
So it very much is something
that started out in music and
then crossed over into
literature and basically was
the underlying conceit for Ralph
Ellison's Invisible Man.
I'll put this back on the
PowerPoint when I post it to
the website.
Oh, it's right here.
My computer is playing
tricks on me.
So this is the passage, and
we can talk about music as
furnishing a chromatic
spectrum to
a linguistic medium.
We don't think of language
necessarily as having colors,
but language very much has
colors in The Great Gatsby.
It's very, very striking.
Blue garden, yellow music,
the blue honey of the
Mediterranean, numerous
instances of color being used
in very abstract ways as
operation, basic operation of
the linguistic medium.
So based on this, the
cross-mapping of music onto
language and the generation of
color as well, it's very, very
odd that sight and sound are
being combined in this
cross-mapping.
So I want to bring this back to
the word that we heard last
time from Maxwell Perkins, his
complaint, really, that The
Great Gatsby is very vague,
that not enough physical
details, not enough info,
really, about Gatsby.
And last time we talked about
it in terms of what I would
call counter-realism.
And today, I would like to
talk about that, that
sensation of vagueness.
I would like to talk about
that in terms of a
cross-mapping of sight and
sound, because this is not
something that we
do all the time.
It's not common usage.
It can create impression of
vagueness, even though once we
get used to it, it's just a
wonderful strategy that
Fitzgerald is using.
So the three headings that
I'd like to use for this
cross-mapping is, first of all,
auditory field with colors.
We've already seen a little bit
of that when Fitzgerald is
seemingly talking about sound,
but colors are operative in
those descriptions.
And then the obverse of that,
the visual field with sound or
with noise, lots of noise.
The same, exactly symmetrical to
that, but happening on the
visual end.
And then the third-- really,
this is the central structure
that I'd like to talk
about today--
is this visual-auditory coupling
as thematic coupling.
So first of all, we see two
characters in the same visual
or the same auditory tableau,
two people seemingly
accidentally being
paired together.
We just see them together.
That's the visual impact
of that image.
And it turns out that that
visual logic, that visual mode
of association actually has
thematic implications.
So the visual-auditory coupling
turning into a
thematic coupling, it's a very
complicated structure, but I
do think that this is something
that Fitzgerald
works very hard to create.
And this is one of the just
miraculous, I would say,
architectural features
of the novel.
So first, let's just
think about the
auditory field with colors.
And this is actually just still
at Gatsby's party and
Nick talking about what he hears
there, but something
else as well.
"The lights grow brighter as
the Earth lurches away from
the Sun, and now the orchestra
is playing yellow cocktail
music, and the opera of voices
pitches a key higher."
So he's really hearing
the music.
This is the occasion when the
"Jazz History of the World" is
being played.
But it seems that it's
impossible to talk about
qualities of sound without
thinking of visual images.
And not even visual images of
the people who were there,
although certainly there are
plenty of descriptions of
those people.
But right now, it's a
very, very cosmic
vision of the world.
"The Earth lurches away from the
Sun." It's on that kind of
cosmic scale, astronomical
scale, that the yellow
cocktail music is
pitching into.
So really the cosmic reference
is coming out of nowhere, and
that was very surprising.
And I'm not sure what to say
about it other than that it
seems very deliberate on
Fitzgerald's part.
So once again, lots and lots of
really interesting details
and packed moments that invite
us, basically, compel us, to
give interpretation to.
So this is one end
of the spectrum,
auditory field with colors.
And so let's go to the other end
of the spectrum, visual,
optical field with noise.
And this is, once again, very
early, when Nick goes to the
Buchanan household for
the first time.
Daisy is his cousin.
He hasn't seen her
for a while.
The first image that he has of
Daisy is actually not of Daisy
alone, but she's on this couch
with another young woman.
"The only completely stationary
object in the room
was an enormous couch on which
two young women were buoyed up
as though upon an anchored
balloon.
They were both in white, and
their dresses were rippling
and fluttering as if they had
just been blown back in after
a short flight around
the house.
I must have stood for a few
moments listening to the whip
and snap of the curtains
and the groan of a
picture on the wall.
Then there was a boom as Tom
Buchanan shut the rear windows
and the caught wind died out
about the room, and the
curtains and the rugs and the
two young women ballooned
slowly to the floor."
It's an amazing image.
And it says a lot the about
Buchanan household.
It says a lot about Daisy.
Basically, it's really
a visual allegory
for the entire novel.
The entire novel of The Great
Gatsby can be seen as Daisy
ballooning up and taking flight,
going back to that
earlier romance with Gatsby.
But really, it's just a very,
very short trip, and she's
going to be brought down
to Earth by Tom.
So it's really interesting
that there should be this
intensification of what might
seem a very neutral or very
casual visual image into
something that carries
tremendous thematic weight.
This is basically the whole
story of The Great Gatsby is
being encapsulated in this
one visual image.
And what allows this visual
image to have such tremendous
thematic weight is actually
an intrusion of
sound into that image.
If there had not been sound,
it would not have been so
pregnant with meaning.
And the sound has to
do with the whip
and snap of the curtains.
It's just remarkable
words to use.
Curtains, they don't make sounds
like a whip, or they
don't make snapping sounds.
So clearly, this is the
superimposition of something
else much more brutal, much
more violent images, being
superimposed--
auditory images being
superimposed upon the
otherwise very benign
and very harmless
sound made by the curtain.
So already, the whip and the
snap already paving the
auditory ground for the
appearance for Tom Buchanan,
so that when he finally appears
towards the end of the
passage, it's almost
not surprising.
Even though he doesn't show up
until the last sentence of the
passage, the snap and
whip of the curtains
already carry his signature.
So it's real interesting that
Tom Buchanan is a very
physical man.
We know him by his physical
attributes, his body filling
up every inch of his clothes,
his riding boots, and so on, a
very visual figure.
But nonetheless, Fitzgerald is
careful to give an auditory
dimension to Tom.
And then the final auditory act
that he does is to bring
down, shut the rear window.
This is not the rear door, but
it's the rear window, almost
as though somebody is trying to
get into his house by the
back door or the back window.
And Tom Buchanan is shutting
that right then and there
before any action
has taken place.
So this is a forecast of
the rest of the novel.
Basically, it's just a capsule
summary of everything that we
need to know about
The Great Gatsby.
So just to see how carefully
crafted this is--
because this is already made,
because this comes to us
ready-made, we don't notice
how much craftsmanship
actually goes into
that passage.
So I just wanted to show you a
visual image that is almost
similar to this by a very
famous painter, Manet.
And this is a picture called
Baudelaire's Mistress,
Reclining.
We also see the curtains
in there.
But we just know that those
curtains are not going to make
a noise like a whip, or they're
not going to be making
whipping or snapping sounds.
So this is in contrast
to Fitzgerald.
This is a visual field
without noise.
It is completely visual.
It doesn't carry the auditory
signature and auditory menace
that is encoded in Fitzgerald's
very careful
coupling of sight and sound
in his description.
So we also know that Daisy
doesn't appear by herself, so
it's very, very important that
she and Jordan Baker--
that the first glimpse that we
have is of the two of them on
that enormous couch, and both
occupants of a visual field
that carries noise.
So that is the first common
thing between
Jordan Baker and Daisy.
Let's go on to see if that
visual-auditory coupling--
what does that mean
in thematic terms?
How does that translate into
features of the plot that
maybe will also bring the
two of them together?
So I'm telling you what I'm--
I'm going to argue this, just
the outline of the lecture,
and then we'll do the
same thing with
Gatsby and Nick as well.
But let's just move on
to Jordan Baker.
And last time, we talked about
the importance of the car, of
Gatsby's Rolls-Royce.
And the car really is a key
player in The Great Gatsby in
all kinds of contexts.
So it turns out that Jordan
Baker, one very important
aspect of her relation
to Nick actually
revolves around the car.
"It was on that same house party
that we had a curious
conversation about
driving a car.
It started because she passed so
close to some workmen that
our fender flicked a button
on one man's coat.
'You're a rotten driver,'
I protested.
'Either you ought to be more
careful, or you oughtn't to
drive at all.' 'I am careful.'
'No, you're not.' 'Well, other
people are,' she said lightly.
'What's that got to do with it?'
'They'll keep out of my
way,' she insisted.
'It takes two to make
an accident.'"
So this says a lot about the
relation between Nick and
Jordan Baker and why it
might come to nothing.
So there are actually lots of
little, local allegories of
the entire plot all the way
throughout The Great Gatsby.
And the fact that she's a bad
driver who's counting on other
people being careful to
prevent accidents from
happening, that is not
a good basis to get
into a marriage with.
And Nick seems to know that, so
this is really one of the
many signs that this is not
going to come to anything.
But what is also interesting, I
think, about this particular
image of Jordan Baker coming by
way of her relation to the
automobile is a notion of
accountability that is perhaps
not just limited to Jordan
Baker herself.
It is really an account, an
explanation of why things go
wrong and one's responsibility,
one's input,
one's contribution to the fact
that something is going wrong.
And for Jordan Baker,
accountability is almost
always written over
to the other side.
If there's an accident, it's
because the other person isn't
a good driver.
That's why there's an accident,
not taking into
account at all the fact that
she's also a bad driver.
She's right that it takes two
to make an accident, but the
explanation that she's looking
for is that it is another
person's fault.
And we'll see that there're
other characters in the novel
who share that understanding of
accountability, kind of a
straight attribution of fault
to the other side.
So let's see how Daisy
relates to the car.
And it turns out that she also
has a very, extremely
nontrivial relation
to the car.
This is while they're leaving
that terrible scene in New
York, when basically Gatsby
is just falling apart.
But Tom allows him to
drive Daisy back.
So Gatsby and Daisy are in the
car, and this is Gatsby
telling Nick what happened.
"When we left New York, she
was very nervous, and she
thought it would steady
her to drive.
And this woman rushed out at us
just as we were passing a
car coming the other way.
It all happened in a minute, but
it seemed to me that she
wanted to speak to us, thought
we were somebody she knew.
Well, first Daisy turned away
from the woman toward the
other car, and then she lost
her nerve and turned back."
So that's the death of Myrtle
at the hand of Daisy.
And it is not intentional.
And I think that this says
a lot about Daisy.
Fitzgerald is not portraying
a bad person, really.
She is a bad driver because
she's lost her nerve.
And we really have to be
pretty careful in our
assignment of blame.
I think that Jordan Baker has
a very, almost too clear
assignment of blame in putting
it squarely on the other
person's side.
And Fitzgerald is actually quite
careful about saying
what kind of a woman Daisy is.
She's just not a very brave
person, and she's not a very
feisty person.
She doesn't have sturdiness of
nerve, and she loses her nerve
at a critical moment, both at
this very critical moment but
also in a kind of abstract way
when Gatsby needed her to
stand by him.
She's really not
there for him.
So this is the kind of person
she is, and it comes out most
dramatically in her handling
of the car.
But it also comes out in the
way that she handles other
affairs of life as well.
So in all those ways, we see
the same logic that we saw
last time-- that is, very
important human attributes are
rooted, are channeled through
our relation to objects.
Daisy's relation to the car says
a lot about how she would
behave in other strictly human
contexts of interaction.
So Jordan Baker and Daisy were
joined together at the very
beginning by virtue of
that visual tableau.
And it turns out that it
actually is a very deep
connection.
They're both bad drivers,
although for bad reasons.
So we have to be careful
as well.
They're both bad drivers, but
in the case of Jordan Baker,
she's just much more cavalier
about the whole thing, whereas
Daisy is just incompetent
and not very
skilled and lacking nerve.
So let's turn back now
to another coupling.
And you guys will notice that
I'm not talking about Gatsby
and Daisy, the most obvious
couple in The Great Gatsby.
But I want to talk about that
couple in a roundabout fashion
actually, by way of
Nick and Gatsby.
And I just want to go back to
one very small point that we
talked about much earlier, which
is about the legacy of
World War I.
So we know that Nick and Gatsby
have this in common.
They both fought in World War
I, and they both named the
units that they were in.
So Nick was in the Ninth Machine
Gun Battalion, and
Gatsby was in the Seventh
Infantry.
Very precise in naming the
number of that unit.
So already, we know that there's
a prior connection
between the two of them.
And I would argue that they
also have an ongoing
connection as well, because
they are both very, very
sensitive to, responsive to,
and captivated by a certain
quality of sound that resides
in Daisy's voice.
So it's very, very odd that
Nick, who has no romantic
attachment to Daisy, should be
captivated in almost exactly
the same way that Gatsby
is captivated.
It doesn't actually take a
romantic attachment for it to
be completely within
the powers of a
certain quality of voice.
So Nick talking about
Daisy's voice.
"It was the kind of voice that
the ear follows up and down,
as if each speech is an
arrangement of notes that will
never be played again.
Her face was sad and lovely
with bright things in it,
bright eyes and a bright
passionate mouth.
But there was an excitement in
her voice that men who had
cared for her found difficult
to forget, a singing
compulsion, a whispered,
'Listen.'"
When we look at the visual
description of Daisy, it's not
very striking.
Fitzgerald is using very,
very generic words
to talk about Daisy.
Her face is "sad and lovely
with bright things in it."
Almost no actual description
of the physical features on
Daisy's face.
So it actually is a very
vague image of Daisy.
We know that supposedly she's
beautiful, but we don't
actually know the
exact features
that render her beautiful.
It is her voice that gives a
very exact rendition of Daisy.
It is a voice that nobody can
forget, that nobody who cares
about her can forget.
And in this case, it is really
the intimation of mortality.
And I think that voice--
well, now we can capture--
obviously, sound recording
makes that less of an
intimation of mortality.
But if it's just a voice that
you hear for that one moment
and you never hear it again,
you do have the sense that
it's just that one time,
and it will never
again be heard again.
If you go to a concert that's
not being recorded, then you
just know that this is it.
Once it's gone, it's gone.
And so that partly accounts for
the compulsion that comes
from Daisy's voice, that it both
is an intimation of her
mortality, and it's an
intimation of mortality on the
part of the person who's
listening to her.
Let's look at one another
description of Daisy's voice
coming from Nick.
This is something that we
actually read before, but I
just thought that I would
read it again.
"For a moment, the last sunshine
fell with romantic
affection upon her
glowing face.
Her voice compelled me forward
breathlessly as I listened.
Then the glow faded, each
light deserting her with
lingering regret, like children
leaving a pleasant
street at dusk."
And this is actually in
the context of Nick--
this is the visit to the
Buchanan household, and Nick
is just about to find out about
Tom's affair with Myrtle.
So in some sense, the fading
light is also a prelude, or
perhaps even an allegory, of the
rapidly fading light, even
in the course of that evening,
as the phone rings, all the
light goes out of
everyone's face.
And so it's the quality of sound
that registers dramatic
development in that episode.
So as I said, Nick really
doesn't have a deep relation
to Daisy, but he
has a very deep
relation to Daisy's voice.
And Gatsby, who has a very deep
relation to Daisy, also
has a very deep relation to
Daisy's voice as well.
And this is the moment when he's
meeting Daisy after all
these years in Nick's house.
And we'll read that passage
a little later.
But Nick conjectures that he's
been keeping her in his heart
for so long that this
is actually not the
big moment for him.
This is actually the moment of
the letdown, that here is this
woman he's been waiting for
all these years, doing
everything, building up his
whole life towards this
moment, and it's a letdown.
And so Nick is noticing that in
Gatsby, and then something
else happens.
"As I watched him, he adjusted
himself visibly.
His hand took hold of hers, and
as she said something low
in his ear, he turned toward
her with a rush of emotion.
I think that voice held him
most, with its fluctuating,
feverish warmth, because it
couldn't be over-dreamed.
That voice was a deathless
song."
So everything else about Daisy
actually could be, and is,
over-dreamed, and Gatsby almost
knows that, that he's
projected much too much onto
Daisy, that there's no way she
can live up to all the
projections of all those years
that he's been involving
her in.
No human being--it's not just
that Daisy can't live up to
that kind of massive projection
on the part of Gatsby.
No human being can.
But one thing about Daisy
can stand up to that
magnification, emotional
magnification and
amplification on the part of
Gatsby, and that is her voice.
Every time, any time he hears
her voice, he's captivated by
her over and over again, as if
everything is really starting
at that moment.
So the voice for Daisy captures
the possibility of
fresh beginning.
It seems to have
come to an end.
It seems to have arrived at
the moment where Gatsby is
finally disillusioned
with Daisy.
And then he hears that voice
again, and it's almost as if
there's a fresh start.
And this is really what
Fitzgerald talks about, about
the new world and the "fresh,
green breast of the new world"
at the very end of The Great
Gatsby is that some people
actually have the capability
for endless new beginnings.
You think that they've come to
the end of the road or that
they come to the end of the
dream, and all of a sudden,
they're starting up
all over again.
And that's really what's
impressive about Gatsby--
sad and pathetic about Gatsby as
well, but also impressive--
is that he can always
start again.
That passion for Gatsby can
always start afresh because of
the quality of Daisy's sound.
But Gatsby is not so captivated
or so blindly in
love that he doesn't know what
is in that voice, what
constitutes that voice, or
what gives the voice its
magical power.
So this is actually a
surprisingly cleared-eye
evaluation of Daisy's
voice from Gatsby.
"'Her voice is full of money,'
he said suddenly.
That was it.
I never understood before.
It was full of money.
That was the inexhaustible charm
that rose and fell in
it, the jingle of it, the
cymbals' song of it.
High in a white palace, the
king's daughter, the golden
girl."
So usually people who are madly
in love are not so great
at analyzing the nature of the
object that they love.
But in a surprising move,
Gatsby actually is very
analytical here and completely
right, that that really is the
power of Daisy, that in some
sense, she is the golden girl,
in a very literal sense, that it
is the gold that makes for
that goldenness of Daisy.
That's really what creates
her, that gives her her
initial magic over Gatsby when
he was just a poor, young boy.
And that's what makes for the
continual magic of Daisy,
that, yes, this is an age of
miracle, as Fitzgerald says
about jazz, but it is an age of
miracle underwritten by the
miracle-creating
power of gold.
This is really what the novel is
about is this magic in this
world, but it's coming from
basically an inanimate,
nonhuman source.
And a human being can quite
often be the creation of that
miracle-working substance,
gold.
So, so far, we've seen the two
of them being completely
captivated by Daisy's voice.
But Nick and Gatsby also have
something else in common as
well, in that even though sound
is what keeps them going
for a good part of the novel,
actually, at some point, sound
is also extinguished for them.
So let's look at the mode
by which sound is being
extinguished for each of them.
And not surprisingly, those come
at the end of the novel,
because when sound is
extinguished, that's also a
signal that the novel
is coming to an end.
So here is Nick actually
watching Tom and Daisy after
the accident when Tom and Daisy
are back in the house.
And Nick is outside, and so he's
watching the two of them.
And all he can see is this
visual tableau of Tom and
Daisy, but he can't hear
what they are saying.
And I think we can really
actually get a more dramatic
moment when you can only
see but not hear.
"Daisy and Tom were sitting
opposite each other at the
kitchen table, with a plate of
cold fried chicken between
them and two bottles of ale.
He was talking intently across
the table at her, and in his
earnestness, his hand
had fallen upon
and covered her own.
Once in a while, she
looked up at him
and nodded in agreement.
They weren't happy, and neither
of them had touched
the chicken or the ale.
And yet they weren't
unhappy either.
There was an unmistakable air of
natural intimacy about the
picture, and anybody would
have said that they were
conspiring together."
So this actually is the "happy
ending," in heavy quotation
marks, for Daisy and Tom, the
reconstitution of that
marriage that had come under
so much stress from both
sides, Myrtle and Gatsby.
And this is another way in which
Myrtle and Gatsby are
linked together.
They're both people coming from
a different social circle
trying to destroy
that marriage.
They are not successful.
The marriage survives.
And this is the comedy,
this is the happy
ending for Tom and Daisy.
And the nature of
that comedy--
and obviously, I'm being
very ironic here--
the nature of the comedy
is that it's
just the two of them.
So really, the marriage is
between the two of them.
Even her cousin can only watch,
but cannot actually
hear what is being said between
the two of them.
So this is a happy moment for
Tom and Daisy that for Nick
has to be experienced as silence
from the part of Daisy
and from Tom.
He's so used to hearing
her voice.
In this one instant, he's not
hearing her voice at all, and
that's because she's
talking to Tom.
She's not talking to Nick.
So let's look at a comparable,
symmetrical moment of sound
being extinguished by Gatsby,
and this is a truly
unforgettable moment.
And once again, all the objects
that we've seen, all
the objects that are imported in
the first part of The Great
Gatsby actually come back and
play a very important part.
So the extinguishing of sound
for Gatsby towards the end of
The Great Gatsby actually comes
by way of the telephone,
nothing coming through to
him from the telephone.
He was waiting, obviously,
for a call from Daisy.
"No telephone message arrived,
but the butler went without
his sleep and waited for it
until 4 o'clock, until long
after there was anyone to
give it to if it came.
I have an idea that Gatsby
himself didn't believe it
would come, and perhaps
he no longer cared.
If that was true, he must have
felt that he had lost the old
warm world, paid a high price
for living too long with a
single dream.
He must have looked up at an
unfamiliar sky through
frightening leaves and shivered
as he found what a
grotesque thing a rose is and
how raw the sunlight is upon
the scarcely created grass."
We see the very carefully
planned transition from the
silence of the telephone
once again to a
strictly visual tableau.
So this is exactly symmetrical
to the scene witnessed by
Nick, the suspension,
non-appearance of sound, and
then the domination of
the visual field.
And now, finally, this is a
visual field without sound.
It hasn't been the
case before.
It's been a visual
field with sound.
Here is a moment when we get
the visual field without
sound, and all of a sudden,
it's a grotesque field.
We don't tend to think of the
rose as a very grotesque
thing, but when you're that up
close to the rose, when you're
seeing it in such minute
features, the rose becomes a
very grotesque thing, unbearable
to look at, really.
And that's really what
the world is for
Gatsby at that point.
So right now, we've talked about
the two of them, Nick
and Gatsby, as if they were
almost exactly alike.
There's this very
strong symmetry
between the two of them.
But obviously, this is really
not exactly our experience of
those two characters, either,
as we read The Great Gatsby.
The two of them are not so
exactly alike that they are
interchangeable.
So I want now to start another
train of thought that actually
points to a difference between
Nick and Gatsby.
Nick and Gatsby have a very
important common ground up to
a certain point, and then they
diverge after that point.
So let's trace the divergence
between them.
It turns out that sound is
extinguished for Nick in two
dramatic scenes.
Not hearing Daisy talking to
Tom, that's one moment.
But there's another one, not
as dramatic, but equally
consequential for him.
And actually, it also comes by
way of a phone conversation.
So at least there's that
symmetry between him and
Gatsby as well.
But here's Nick talking
to Jordan Baker.
This is after the accident.
"'Suppose I don't go to
Southampton and come into town
this afternoon?' 'No, I don't
think this afternoon.' 'Very
well.' 'It's impossible
this afternoon.
Various--' We talked like that
for a while, and then abruptly
we weren't talking any longer.
I don't know which of us hung
up with a sharp click, but I
know I didn't care."
So here too is a phone
conversation that simply turns
into a non-conversation, and
then silence descending on the
two of them.
So it seems this scene obviously
is very, very close
to the silence of the telephone
for Gatsby.
But there is a crucial
difference.
Nick had conjectured earlier
that Gatsby didn't care if the
phone call came or not, but
that's obviously not true.
How could he not care?
He was devastated.
It was devastating that there
was no phone call from Daisy.
But this is a moment when Nick
truly doesn't really care.
And he doesn't care because
of who he is.
So now we've come to a very
important parting of the ways
between Nick and Gatsby.
Gatsby is someone who actually
cares so much that it's almost
as if there's no reason for him
to live after that moment,
and so it's fitting that he
should die right then and
there, the plot almost
reflecting his psychology.
But Nick is someone who doesn't
care and who survives
in some sense because
he doesn't care.
So here's a moment to go back
to, something that Fitzgerald
and Hemingway actually
have in common.
We talked a lot about the
logic of substitution in
Hemingway, and especially the
picador's horse being the
substitute for the picador
when a bull is charging.
So there's a very important
logic of
substitution in Hemingway.
And it turns out that there's
also a logic of substitution
in The Great Gatsby as well,
if only because the word
"substitute" is actually used by
Fitzgerald, once again in a
seemingly gratuitous context.
But this is the family history
of Nick Carraway.
"The actual founder of my line
was my grandfather's brother,
who came here in '51, sent a
substitute to the Civil War,
and started the wholesale
hardware business that my
father carries on today."
This entire passage, when we
first read it, seems to have
nothing to do with the
rest of the novel.
Why would we care whether or
not back one generation--
and not even his grandfather,
but his uncle, grand-uncle--
sent a substitute?
He didn't fight.
So this actually has a
lot in common with
the Hemingway story.
This is someone who doesn't
fight his own battle.
He sends a substitute to fight
for him and to suffer for him
in the Civil War.
And then as a consequence of
surviving because of not
having died in the Civil War,
being able to found a very
successful hardware business.
So all these details about
Nick's family history, at the
moment when it appears, very
early, the opening pages of
The Great Gatsby, seems simply
just to stand there and to be
doing nothing.
And it's only in hindsight that
we can impute a meaning.
We can retrospectively impute
a meaning to that original
seemingly gratuitous detail.
And it really has to do with the
vital difference between
Gatsby and Nick.
And here is this moment when--
just before Gatsby is
captivated by Daisy's
voice again--
this is the moment of this
illusion but also re-illusion
that Nick is noticing
in Gatsby.
"There must have been moments
even that afternoon when Daisy
stumbled short of his dreams,
not through her own fault, but
because of the colossal vitality
of his illusion.
It had gone beyond her,
beyond everything.
He had thrown himself into it
with a creative passion,
adding to it all the time,
decking it out with every
bright feather that
drifted his way.
No amount of fire or freshness
can challenge what a man can
store up in his ghostly
heart."
So this is really why Gatsby is
what he is, is that he has
this enormous storage capacity
in his ghostly heart.
And Daisy will be stored
there forever.
It almost doesn't matter who
she is, what she really
turns out to be.
And when he finally realized
what she is, it
almost doesn't matter.
It has no relation to reality at
all, because it is strictly
a dream about Daisy that Gatsby
has stored up in his
own heart and mind.
So the colossal vitality of
illusion, and that is what's
deathless about Daisy in
Gatsby's own mind and what
enables Gatsby to be deathless
to some extent as well, in
spite of his physical,
biological death.
With Nick, it's the
other way around.
So I just wanted to read you why
he doesn't care and why it
turns out that his family
business is
the hardware business.
It is someone who can never
be hurt by anything
that happens to him.
"Jordan Baker was incurably
dishonest. She wasn't able to
endure being at a disadvantage,
and given this
unwillingness, I suppose she
had begun dealing in
subterfuges when she was very
young in order to keep that
cool, insolent smile turned to
the world and yet satisfy the
demands of her hard,
jaunty body."
We have seen Gatsby be very
analytical about Daisy, that
her voice is "full of money."
And here is Nick performing a
comparable analytic operation
on Jordan Baker, that she's
just incurably dishonest,
she can't bear to lose.
She will do anything
she can to win.
He's right about Jordan Baker.
That's why the marriage is
not going to take place.
But more than that, it's not
even that she's not such a
great marriage companion.
It is that Nick really doesn't
even care enough to be hurt by
that realization.
He is insulated by the emotional
hardware that has
been his family's business for
these two generations.
And so that's why the family
history is so important to
Nick and why he really needs
a substitute, because he is
simply incapable of feeling
the ecstasy that Gatsby is
capable of feeling.
Nor is he capable of feeling the
devastation that Gatsby is
capable of feeling.
Those two go hand in hand.
You get ecstasy, you
get devastation.
Nick is not capable of either.
And that's why he's such good
friends with Gatsby and why
he's always standing by Gatsby,
because he really
needs that indirect experience
of what it feels to be in
Gatsby's mind and to have that
ghostly heart with its
miraculous storage capacity.
So anyway, this is Fitzgerald's
way of
encouraging us to think about
different constellations,
different configurations,
different constellations of
characters.
And Nick and Gatsby are not the
most obvious couple, but
it turns out that actually the
whole story of The Great
Gatsby can be told by looking at
this nontraditional couple.
And I would encourage you in
section to think of other
nontraditional couples
as well.
And we'll turn to Faulkner
next week.